Trascrizione: Alejandro Minnelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
La semplicità ci piace.
È semplice, comoda.
Ci piace così tanto
che tutti - io, voi -
abbiamo una sorta di naturale tendenza
a semplificare ogni cosa:
in un certo senso per capirla,
ma anche per non averne paura.
La semplicità ci dà
l'illusione del controllo.
È quella che ci fa credere
che possiamo prendere delle scatole,
metterci delle etichette sopra
e infilarci dentro cose,
pensieri, persone.
Ci tranquillizza anche
quando pensiamo per opposti,
perché è semplice e immediato:
bianco-nero, uomo-donna,
giusto-sbagliato, normale-diverso.
Anche a me piace molto la semplicità.
Sono infatti una di quelle persone
che raggruppa le applicazioni
del telefono per colore:
questa è davvero una foto
del mio telefono.
E mi piacciono anche quei video
dove ci sono quelle cose che si incastrano
perfettamente tra di loro
perché mi dà un senso
di pace e tranquillità
vedere ogni cosa
al proprio posto, in ordine.
Eppure so che mi sto
aggrappando a un'illusione,
perché la realtà è molto
più complessa di così,
e sto limitando quindi
la mia visione del mondo.
Quando parliamo di sessualità,
questo errore di semplificazione
è particolarmente comune.
Crediamo infatti che si possa essere
una o l'altra cosa,
in maniera molto binaria.
Possiamo essere uomini o donne.
Possiamo essere etero o gay.
Possiamo anche essere
monogami o non monogami.
Tutte caratteristiche opposte,
e dai confini ben definiti.
Quando io ero al liceo,
questa tendenza a semplificare
mi ha decisamente portato
a un momento di crisi,
in particolare quando mi misi a chiedermi
se effettivamente mi piacessero
gli uomini o le donne.
Ecco, ne parlai con un amico;
e questo, con tutta la tranquillità
del mondo, mi rispose:
"Beh, ma perché scegliere?
Magari ti piacciono entrambi".
Entrambi?
Non avevo idea che potesse essere
un'opzione, in effetti;
e quindi subito provai una forte sorpresa,
che però si tramutò anche presto
in un grande sollievo,
perché non mi piaceva
l'idea di dover scegliere:
mi sembrava limitante e ingiusto.
Ecco perché comprendere
che la mia sessualità fosse valida,
anche se non l'avevo mai vista
raccontata, o rappresentata,
ha fatto del bene
alla relazione con me stessa.
Però ha anche iniziato
ad aprirmi gli occhi
su quanto potesse esserci
oltre quello che siamo soliti raccontarci.
Infatti, anche la scienza,
e la storia, ci dimostrano
che la sessualità è molto più complessa
di quello che pensiamo.
Ci sono anche tante teorie, e tanti studi,
che cercano di dare valore
a questa complessità.
Innanzitutto, intendiamoci:
la sessualità non riguarda
solo il sesso in senso stretto,
ma è un universo amplissimo,
pieno di elementi
ma tutti dai confini sfumati.
Mio padre è un medico,
ora in realtà è felicemente in pensione,
e una volta a tavola decisi di chiedergli
cosa volesse dire,
per lui, essere un uomo.
In effetti,  giustamente rimase
un po' stranito dalla domanda
e alzando lo sguardo dal piatto,
mi rispose: "Non saprei,
non me lo sono mai chiesto".
Lo capisco.
Lo capisco perfettamente,
perché non è facile farsi domande
sulla propria identità di genere.
Capire cosa voglia dire per noi
essere uomini, essere donne
o qualsiasi altra cosa
non è facile,
perché non esiste una risposta
più giusta o valida.
Nella nostra società
ci sono norme per ogni cosa;
e quando non ci facciamo domande
su queste norme,
potrebbe essere semplicemente
che le stiamo seguendo
senza farci troppe domande.
Come mio padre.
E vi dirò in realtà, anche,
un'altra verità ossimoricamente scomoda.
Se non ci siamo mai fatti domande,
non abbiamo mai messo
in discussione queste norme,
forse, in fondo in fondo,
ci fanno anche stare comodi.
Allora io qua vi suggerisco di chiedervi:
perché ci stiamo comodi,
se davvero ci stiamo comodi,
e se qualcun altro, invece,
potrebbe starci stretto.
Infatti, nella nostra società,
c'è una norma per tutto:
ci dice come dev'essere un uomo,
come dev'essere una donna.
Ci dice anche come si devono vestire
e cosa devono fare.
Ci dice chi dobbiamo amare,
come dobbiamo amarlo e con quali tappe.
Tutte norme create
per sfuggire alla complessità
come dei copioni già scritti,
semplicemente da seguire alla lettera.
Perché l'incertezza spaventa,
e non possiamo biasimare
chi si rifugia nella semplicità.
Lo facciamo tutti.
Anch'io.
Anch'io, per tanto tempo,
mi sono rintanata nel comfort delle norme.
Finché, come fossero vecchie scarpe,
semplicemente non mi resi conto
che mi stavano davvero, davvero strette.
Forse perché fino ad allora non sapevo
che ci fossero delle alternative.
Non sapevo che potevo chiedermi:
"Ma queste scarpe mi stanno ancora comode?
Ma queste scarpe sono ancora mie?".
E forse è un po' questo
quello che vorrei fare qui con voi oggi.
Ricordarvi e ricordarci
che abbiamo delle alternative
ad un modo univoco
e binario di guardare le cose.
Vorrei che ogni persona
potesse essere in grado
di scegliere se e quando semplificare,
senza però obbligare gli altri
anche a fare lo stesso.
Vorrei che potessimo vedere, accettare,
rispettare la complessità
della nostra sessualità
e della nostra vita in generale,
riscoprirne i confini
e ribaltarne i paradigmi.
Proviamo a immaginare un prato.
Un prato verde, brillante,
da cui sbucano fiori
di ogni tipo e colore.
Proviamo a immaginarci, davvero,
di star percorrendo questo prato;
e camminando tra gli steli d'erba,
raggiungiamo una leggera salita
che ci porta sulla cima di una collina,
da cui guardiamo oltre.
Di fronte a noi si estende
un panorama mozzafiato, ricco e variegato.
Ci sono laghi, montagne, pianure, colline.
Forse, se guardiamo bene bene,
in fondo c'è anche il mare.
E nessuno di questi elementi
è più o meno bello,
o necessario, dell'altro.
E se vi dicessi
che possiamo prendere questo panorama
come fosse la nostra sessualità?
Si tratta di una metafora della scienziata
e studiosa canadese Sari Van Anders,
che ci insegna
che quando impariamo a distinguere
tra le pianure, le montagne,
i laghi, i fiumi,
allora iniziamo anche a realizzare
quante esperienze della sessualità
ci sono là fuori.
Ed è da qui, da questa realizzazione
che si parte alla scoperta
di questo panorama.
Oppure abbiamo anche tutto il diritto
di rimanere esattamente dove siamo,
ma con una consapevolezza in più.
Ogni persona ha una mappa
che cambia con il tempo,
e che le permette
di esplorare questo panorama.
Quindi come possiamo pensare che esista
una mappa adatta a tutti e sempre?
È difficile, però a volte
tendiamo a crederlo;
e quindi tendiamo anche a credere
che esista una normalità
a cui puntare, a cui aderire.
Sono ancora tantissime, tantissime
le persone che si rivolgono a me -
o alla mia associazione,
che si chiama "Virgin & Martyr",
e ha proprio l'obiettivo
di portare più consapevolezza
nell'educazione sessuale e socio-emotiva -
che ci chiedono se sono normali:
se i loro corpi, i loro desideri,
le loro identità sono normali.
Ma cosa vuol dire normale?
Normale rispetto a cosa?
E in realtà credo che,
invece di parlare di normalità,
possa interessarci di più parlare
di ciò che è comune,
contraddistinto da ciò
che è normale per noi.
Facciamo due esempi, molto semplici.
È molto comune avere due mani.
Eppure una persona che nasce
con solo una mano?
Sicuramente, quella non sarà
una condizione comune;
ma è la sua normalità.
Pensiamo anche
che sia più comune essere attratti
da un genere che è diverso dal nostro.
Eppure, questo non rende
questo tipo di attrazione
più valido di altri.
E allora, anziché chiederci
se siamo normali,
proviamo a chiederci
chi siamo, cosa vogliamo,
cosa ci fa star bene e che cosa no.
Perché, anche se sembrano
domande semplici,
le risposte sono molto complesse;
e quindi non è facile porsele.
Se continuiamo a credere
che esista una normalità,
allora saremo anche portati a credere
che possiamo essere sbagliati,
se non rispecchiamo
certi finti standard tanto osannati.
E allora, in questo modo è chiaro
che veniamo portati a provare rancore
anche nei nostri stessi confronti
se non rispecchiamo quegli standard,
se non siamo abbastanza normali.
E per l'ennesima volta
io lo capisco, questo,
perché anch'io ho combattuto
tante battaglie contro me stessa.
Mi sono incolpata,
mi sono giudicata, mi sono ferita.
Me la sono presa con me,
invece che prendermi per mano
e permettermi di esplorare il panorama
secondo le mie regole.
Ecco perché penso
che parte della soluzione
sia proprio il lavoro individuale
che ciascuno di noi può fare su se stesso.
Quello che ho imparato nel mio percorso,
e che mi ha permesso di allontanarmi
dall'idea di non essere abbastanza,
è stato un lento e graduale
cambio di approccio nei miei confronti.
Ho iniziato a capire
che per affrontare tutte
le difficoltà di questo mondo
è importante che io sia
la mia più grande amica,
sostenitrice e alleata.
Che devo ringraziarmi
per tutto quello che faccio,
anche nei giorni no.
Che posso coccolarmi,
permettermi di stare bene
e smetterla di giudicarmi.
Essere gentili con noi stessi
è sicuramente un approccio
che può migliorare con il tempo,
e una scelta attiva che tutti
possiamo fare ogni giorno.
Però non basta.
Non basta se non lo uniamo
a un lavoro culturale.
Perché serve infatti uno sforzo collettivo
per evolvere come società
e sostituire norme e confini
definiti omologanti
in una cultura che celebri l'unicità
delle nostre esperienze e prospettive.
E allora, se ognuno di noi è parte attiva
della propria cultura,
e ha quindi la responsabilità
di fare qualcosa, qualsiasi cosa
sia nelle sue mani
per permettere a ciascuno di noi
di percorrere il panorama
secondo le nostre regole,
allora è importante che facciamo qualcosa.
Iniziamo col confrontare
le nostre mappe, i nostri panorami.
Proviamo a aprire
dialoghi onesti e rispettosi
su tutto ciò che riguarda
il corpo, le identità, le emozioni.
E facciamolo a scuola, a casa,
in famiglia e anche al lavoro.
Perché abbiamo tutto il diritto
di essere noi stessi.
Quindi sì:
riscoprire e ampliare la nostra visione,
rispettando quella altrui,
è davvero possibile,
e può fare davvero tanta paura.
Ma vogliamo mettere quanto più spazio c'è
per essere noi stessi?
Grazie.
(Applausi)